und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und bettina schausten
guten abend 22 uhr 46 morgen um diese
zeit wissen wir vielleicht schon wer
fußball europameister ist dass wir nicht
wissen ist ob sich das finale im
londoner wembley stadion als super
stretta event erweisen wird mit einem
klaren sieger dem corona virus in der
delta variante wie schon zum halbfinal
werden erneut 65.000 menschen erwartet
und sollte england gewinnen dürfte
landesweit kein halten mehr sein
das alles erscheint so atemberaubend
sorglos wie riskant und gefährlich
andreas stamm berichtet aus london das
ganz im zeichen des morgigen endspiels
steht um england in diesen tagen zu
verstehen braucht es jenes lächeln aus
der vergangenheit die queen gratuliert
den englischen weltmeistern in wembley
der einzige titel 66 danach weiht sich
enttäuschung anschlag und so erklären
sich diese bilder
england im fußballrausch endlich wieder
finale
doch was in der euphorie unter geht jede
musik steigt zwar die begeisterung
genauso aber auch die zahl der korona
infektion menschenmassen im stadion in
papst bei privat feiern überall in den
kommenden wochen wird das bei den
infektionen zu heftigen ausschlägen nach
oben führen und einweisungen ins
krankenhaus habe werden zu die regierung
rechnet mit bis zu 100.000
neuinfektionen am 19 juli
dennoch sollen an diesem tag alle corona
beschränkungen fallen 50 prozent der
bevölkerung seien doppelt geimpft
deshalb würden schwere verläufe und
todesfälle auf relativ niedrigem niveau
bleiben
diesen ansatz erklären 122 forscher in
einem offenen brief für
verantwortungslos einer von fünf
neuinfizierten werde an longo witt
leiden auch jüngere und erkranken
millionen werde es wahrscheinlicher dass
eine impfstoff resistente variante
entstehe
dazu kommen weitere probleme
hunderttausende briten werden gerade von
der korona the pin zehntägige
selbstisolation geschickt nun wird die
app massenhaft deaktiviert hohe
fallzahlen alles ist wieder geöffnet
viele werden kontaktiert die regierung
sagt nun wir werden die app weniger
empfindlich machen oder die leute
löschen sie gleich großartig einfach die
alarmfunktion abschalten damit man das
problem ignorieren kann
doch warnungen aller art gehen gerade
runter fußballfeste feiern und öffnen in
der del-tabelle ein experiment der
regierung johnson mit hohem risiko dass
es schief geht
damit es wenigstens sportlich ein erfolg
wird gab es heute für die mannschaft um
nationalcoach southgate ein
motivationsschreiben der queen in dem
sie den siegeswillen des teams lobte die
party dürfte im falle eines englischen
triumphs ein noch nicht gekanntes ausmaß
annehmen und in die pandemie geschichte
eingehen so fürchten biologen als super
sprecher sonntag herdenimmunität zu
erreichen über eine hohe impfquote das
also muss das ziel sein überall nicht
über eine vielzahl von infizierten
hierzulande haben rund 42 prozent den
doppelten impfschutz
das reiche nicht darauf weiß
gesundheitsminister sparen heute hin
im wettlauf mit der delta variante und
ruft dazu auf sich impfen zu lassen
appell gegen sorglosigkeit zu der die
aktuellen inzidenz zahlen manchem anlass
geben die zwar leicht steigen aber auf
niedrigem niveau liegen was ist diese
zahl überhaupt noch wert inzidenz bei
steigender impfquote darüber wird
diskutiert wie felix jochens zeigt
[Musik]
die höhe dieser werte entscheidet über
unseren alltag in der pandemie ab ende
april geht es mit der sieben tage
inzidenz steil bergab
seit dienstag dieser woche wieder leicht
bergauf doch ist die inzidenz noch der
wichtigste faktor zur beurteilung der
lage
wichtig wäre die krankheitslast zu
messen also gibt es personen die
hospitalisiert werden
die auf die intensivstation kommen die
intubiert werden also beatmet werden und
sterben
und diese zahlen muss man sich viel
konkreter anschauen ende april wurden
noch über 5000 menschen in deutschland
wegen einer corona infektion
intensivmedizinisch behandelt jetzt sind
es 434 die entwicklung schwer abzusehen
vor allem aufgrund der delta variante
die inzidenz sei hier geeignet als
frühwarnsystem bei den infektionen wenn
die hoch gehen dann wenn ich dann
eingreifen dann kann ich tatsächlich ein
höheres maß an schweren verläufen
verhindern
als wenn ich erst eingreifen wenn die
intensivstation aufnahmen hochgehen
und doch liegt in der luft das der
inzidenz wert in zukunft weniger
bedeutung haben wird die impfkampagne
schreitet voran die älteren sind zumeist
geschützt
dadurch droht bei höherer instanz nicht
mehr automatisch eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems der blick in die
kliniken von immer mehr experten als
wichtiger indikator gefordert das ist
übrigens so viele im schwenzer gebe die
ihre termine verfallen ließen darüber
wurde diese woche ja viel gesprochen
scheint gar nicht so zu sein jedenfalls
stützt eine umfrage in den bundesländern
die die frankfurter allgemeine
sonntagszeitung durchgeführt hat diesen
verdacht nicht
detaillierte informationen zu den
impfquoten hier und in anderen ländern
finden sie sehr gut aufbereitet bei zdf
heute.de und in unserer zdf heute ein
monat nach der landtagswahl in sachsen
anhalt die mit dem sehr deutlichen sieg
für die cdu endete kommt die
regierungsbildung voran eine deutschland
koalition ist das ziel die so heißt weil
sie schwarz rot und nicht gold aber gelb
zusammenführen
cdu spd und fdp also die grünen sind
raus das ist insofern interessant weil
es nach jahrzehnten ein novum wäre
eines das auch für den bund
gedankenspiele auslöst diese deutschland
koalition und weil ein dreierbündnis
eigentlich nicht nötig wäre denn cdu und
spd hätten auch allein eine knappe
mehrheit die spd landesspitze segnete
den plan heute ab und das obwohl ihr das
bündnis mit der cdu genauso wie im bund
wahrlich nicht gut tut andreas weise
berichtet welterbestadt quedlinburg in
sachsen-anhalt kulisse für eine sitzung
von spd landesvorstand und parteirat mit
ihrem erbe tun sich die sozialdemokraten
derzeit schwer schon wieder
stimmenverluste nach einer koalition mit
der cdu
seit 2011 von 21,5 auf 8,4 prozent
gefallen
mancher sozialdemokrat will lieber in
die opposition
doch nach fünf stunden debatte hinter
verschlossenen türen ein deutliches
ergebnis der parteirat und der
landesvorstand geben die empfehlung
koalitionsverhandlungen mit cdu und fdp
aufzunehmen wir haben uns das nicht
leicht gemacht wir haben diese
entscheidung in verantwortung für das
land getroffen
aber sie ist mit deutlicher mehrheit
ausgesprochen regieren ja oder nein
diese frage zerriss die bundes partei
fast nach der letzten bundestagswahl wie
die landesparteien sachsen anhalt
antwortet der parteitag nächsten freitag
wird es zeigen
ich glaube allerdings dass wir dass es
keine entweder oder entscheidung ist
zu sagen wenn wir in die opposition
gehen ist es gut für die spd sondern die
frage wie wir weder land mehr land unter
die füße kriegen und wieder stabiler
werden ist glaube ich nicht eine frage
von regierung oder opposition
das ist ein neues dreierbündnis für
sachsen anhalt geben soll
am mittwoch wurde das klappt schwarz rot
gelb die sogenannte deutschland
koalition rückt nach den sondierungen
immer näher
die letzten drei bis vier wochen hier in
den sondierungsgesprächen die machen
mich aber sehr optimistisch dass es wenn
die gremien entsprechend auch zustimmen
und wieder in den koalitionsgesprächen
auch gute ergebnisse zu erzielen werden
dass wir dann eine koalition hätten eine
deutschland koalition die sicherlich
erstmal einmalig ist in deutschland aber
die dieses bundesland sachsen anhalt
definitiv voranbringen und fdp statt
grüne viele in der cdu sind heilfroh
dabei wollten die liberalen ursprünglich
gar nicht mitmachen haben doch cdu und
spd zusammen eine stimme mehrheit im
neuen magdeburger landtag
doch nicht alle cdu-abgeordneten gelten
als 100-prozentige teamplayer
vor allem ministerpräsident haseloff
will deutlich mehr stabilität zum
regieren durch die neue dreier koalition
sie sorgt für eine gewisse einigkeit
innerhalb der cdu also kleine
grabenkämpfe sind da nicht mehr wichtig
denn die koalition ihre mehrheit werden
davon nicht gefährdet auch nicht von
krankheitsfällen das heißt die mehrheit
ist sicher schwarz- rot- gelb- der weg
dahin ist begonnen aber noch lang
stimmen alle drei parteien
koalitionsverhandlungen zu soll bis
mitte september die neue landesregierung
stehen
und jetzt zu den nachrichten die mit
einer entscheidung beginnen die manche
schon jetzt historisch nennen sagen wir
es ist auf dem weg dahin eine durch die
g20-finanzminister die sind die
führenden industrie und handel starten
die haben einen weiteren schritt gemacht
in richtung einer globalen steuerreform
mit einer weltweiten mindeststeuer von
15 prozent für große unternehmen
das bei einem treffen in venedig
vereinbarte konzept sieht auch vor dass
künftig mehr steuern dort gezahlt werden
sollen wo das jeweilige unternehmen
seine gewinne erzielt finanzminister
scholz spricht von einem historischen
moment
ein moment bei dem eine hundertjährige
praxis der internationalen besteuerung
von unternehmen geändert wird
die g 20 staaten haben sich jetzt hier
darauf verständigt dass sie ein neues
eine neue ordnung der internationalen
besteuerung miteinander vereinbaren
wollen
nun sollen noch offene fragen geklärt
werden bis oktober zum gipfel der g20
staats und regierungschefs der grünen co
vorsitzende robert habeck hat angesichts
der kritik an der kanzlerkandidatin der
partei annalena baerbock versichert dass
ein wechsel der kanzlerkandidatur kein
thema sei in einem interview mit der
süddeutschen zeitung sagte habeck die
grünen hätten berbalk gerade erst mit
nahezu 100 prozent zu ihrer
kanzlerkandidatin gewählt jetzt gehe es
darum aus diesem vertrauensvorschuss den
sie von der partei gekommen habe das
beste zu machen
dauerregen hat in vielen gemeinden
süddeutschlands zu hochwasser geführt im
fränkischen ölfeld pumpte die feuerwehr
voll gelaufene keller aus vielerorts
waren flüsse gefährlich angeschwollen
und hatten straßen überflutet allein im
landkreis neustadt an der aisch waren
mehr als 1300 einsatzkräfte beschäftigt
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
28 25 32 40 47 superzahl 6 und weitere
gewinnern finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf
de und dem zdf text auf seite 55 7
es gibt unwetterwarnungen des deutschen
wetterdienstes vor schwerem gewitter mit
heftigem starkregen und hagel für teile
bayerns
und die wetteraussichten für morgen in
einem streifen vom emsland bis
niederbayern schauer und gewitter später
auch im nordosten sonst freundlich und
häufiger sonne 20 bis 28 grad
die weiteren aussichten am montag
anfangs sonnig später sowie auch in den
nächsten tagen kräftige schauer und
gewitter
sie war eine stimme gegen den hass gegen
das vergessen heute ist diese stimme
verstummt
die musikerin und zeitzeugin esther
bejarano war holocaust-überlebende
mitglied des mädchen orchesters in
auschwitz die musik sagte sie selbst
habe sie wohl gerettet
96 ist sie geworden eine der wenigen
letzten die von den verbrechen der
nationalsozialisten aus eigenem erleben
berichten konnte und es tat jungen
leuten sagte 7 ihr habt keine schuld an
dem was passiert ist aber ihr macht euch
schuldig wenn ihr nichts über diese zeit
wissen wollt bundespräsident steinmeier
würdigte heute ihre mutige
persönlichkeit die sich bis zuletzt für
die verfolgten des naziregimes
eingesetzt habe hamburg war ihre
wahlheimat von dort greift zimmermann
von sievert dies sind bilder vom
vergangenen mai von ihrem so genannten
zweiten geburtstag so bezeichnete es der
bgh ihre befreiung durch amerikanische
und sowjetische soldaten im mai 45 bis
zuletzt kämpfte sie nicht nur für den 8
mai als nationalen feiertag sondern ihr
ganzes langes leben hindurch gegen
faschismus antisemitismus und rassismus
ist meine rache dass ich in schulen gehe
dass ich den schülern und den
jugendlichen erzählen was damals geschah
weil sie es einfach nicht wussten wenn
man ihnen einfach nichts erzählt und
weil es keinen entnazifizierung gott
überhaupt nicht musikalisch machte sie
bis ins hohe alter front gegen rechte
gewalt und rechtsextremismus mit der
microphone mafia einer repr gruppe
[Musik]
auschwitz hatte sie wohl nur überlebt
weil sie akkordeon spielte im
mädchenorchester die todeslager der
nazis wurden zu ihrem lebenstraum die
musik zu ihrem lebensretter dass wir da
stehen mussten und musik machen mussten
und die leute uns zugewunken haben in
den zügen und gedacht haben wo es sich
nur um musik spielt da kann es ja nicht
so schlimm sein ja das war für uns das
schlimmste
entsetzt zeigte sie sich immer wieder
über die heutige rechtsextreme gewalt
auf deutschlands straßen
so blieb sie bis zuletzt im besten sinne
eine unberührte kämpferin für recht und
freiheit in aus wut habe ich zu meinen
freundinnen immer gesagt wir müssen das
überleben wir dürfen einfach nicht
schlapp machen und ich möchte nicht dass
nochmal so etwas passiert wie damals nie
wieder
esther bejarano ja so viel für heute von
uns wir geben jetzt gleich ab wann
sportstudio vorlauf natürlich fürs
finale morgen und danach so gegen 0 uhr
gibt es dann die nächste heute express
wir sehen uns morgen in der halbzeit
wieder sinn
[Musik]